Paul and Jack Rudd Paul another Super
Bowl champion I can't believe it I
really that's such a that was such a
great game I just want to thank Patrick
Mahomes for existing
I cannot believe he's a real person and
we cannot believe this family
resemblance oh you know there's a little
game going on that game Super Bowl 57
where Fox Sports caught up with Kansas
City native Paul Rudd right after the
Chiefs earned the coveted trophy I can't
believe it I really that's such a it was
such a great game and uh wow it's all
just feels so overwhelming and
incredible also on the sidelines Paul's
17 year old son jack who looks a whole
lot like his famous dad and they even
sound alike wow this is awesome I'm so
lucky that I am alive to watch this I
just want to thank Patrick Mahomes for
existing for putting in all the work so
we can just all enjoy his greatness
every week and like I don't know how to
explain it I just can't believe he's a
real person but the Reds aren't the only
ones obsessed with the newly minted MVP
right now Patrick Mahomes is like my
favorite quarterback in the NFL
I just made commercials for Kansas City
for the playoffs Patrick and me
and I just say
I found out for the first time what no
body fat meant but back to Paul we're
glad the actor could breathe a sigh of
relief because leading up to game day he
told E.T he was on pins and needles
pretty pretty exciting I'm with you but
I'm not nervous for some reason Paul
you're not nervous no I'm not nervous I
think we're good that's the kind of
thing if I ever said that I would have
to get up and spin around three times
and I'm not kidding I get so
superstitious thankfully Mahomes led the
Chiefs to a 38-35 victory against the
Philadelphia Eagles and the Kansas City
Chiefs have won Super Bowl 57.
there's one show in town this week and
this ain't it yeah the Big Show for Paul
was the big game but Marvel heads are
still pretty excited for more Scott Lang
in Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania am
I the Hulk's baby dad are you listening
to your own book but I was ready for it
no that's uh Stephen this is the radio
when I told my own son that I was going
to be in a superhero movie he asked me
what it was I said we would be playing
Ant-Man and he said what and they said
Ant-Man and he he was not that impressed
one question
is it too late to change the name what
he actually said was well I can't wait
to see how stupid that'll be stop it I
swear to God that's what he said no he
didn't which really made me laugh Apple
doesn't fall far from the tree then huh
sounds like something you witnessed yeah
no it really and the timing of the way
he said it too was well he took a pause
right on can't wait to see how stupid
that'll be fast forward to 2023 we hope
Jax warmed up to his dad's superhero
role and one thing's for sure Jack loved
dad's A-list invite to the Super Bowl
I'm so lucky that I am alive to watch
this
foreign